we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we'll jump into our next call from the
337 area code caller what's your name
and where are you calling from today
hello Kate this is our Gabriel calling
from Youngsville Louisiana great what's
on your mind ok so I haven't seen a lot
of interviews with live with Warren
where she had some things like the
Kennedy no mansion and refusing to
explain why she endorsed Princeton and I
was just wondering what your takeaway
was on why she was doing this and if she
could still be progressive fighters for
people if you know what I mean yeah good
question so we talked about during an
interview with The Young Turks Jen
Kyogre Elizabeth Warren was asked why
didn't you endorse it you know you're
you're almost as liberal you're the
second most progressive senator in the
Senate basically behind Bernie Sanders
why didn't you endorse him during the
primary and he'll of the Elizabeth
Warren did not answer the question she
just said something along the lines of
I'm proud of how the Democratic primary
went which is crazy I mean it was an
embarrassment at the primary when and
then when it was decided I came out and
supported Hillary Clinton and I would
have supported Bernie Sanders and it was
it was just a total non answer you're
also right that she has been sort of
defending Joe Manchin widely considered
to be I guess the most conservative
Democrat in the Senate is that fair to
say Pat Joe Manchin from West Virginia
typically thought of as the most
conservative Democrat listen everybody
all to West Virginia at when you're in
West Virginia you can't be that liberal
that's for sure
so I don't know the answer as to why
Elizabeth Warren is doing this I would
love to hear more directly from her uh
generally why it is that she's been
saying these things I don't think you're
going to get anything more than a
politician's answer if I had to
speculate I would say number one it's
because she doesn't want to be involved
in any kind of internal fighting within
the Democratic Party which is crazy
because her not answer about Bernie is
creating a problem within the Democratic
Party where now you have a wing of
people who supported Bernie that are now
hearing what Elizabeth Warren said and
saying scratching their head saying wait
a second what that's not really a good
answer the other possibility is and I'm
floating this only as a possibility it's
possible that
Elizabeth Warren may not actually be as
progressive as some people believe her
to be right that's another possibility
that we could also consider although we
don't have any specific evidence really
to suggest that I think we're also
learning a lot from the interview that
shank had with her to because he would
ask questions that probably no one else
would ask so for example he also asked
why she allowed Ben Carson's nomination
to go to the floor of the Senate right
and then later she voted against him but
apparently she was convinced that he was
really interested on leads effect on
child's brain yes and so obviously you
shouldn't have led in public housing and
that was enough for her to get behind
putting him to a vote yeah that's right
that's right so anyway Gabriel I don't
know if we answered your question
because there's really no way to know
the answer but that those are some of my
thoughts yeah I never really thought
about possible yet she could be less
progressive than she put on yeah I'm not
saying that as an ad hominem by the way
and I know that there's a whole thing
going on now people are like don't
criticize Elizabeth Warren ever I'm just
thinking out loud I like Elizabeth
Warren she's been in our studio and
again she and Bernie are the two most
progressive senators to most progressive
senators and Democrats in the Senate all
right Gabriel thanks very much
appreciate the call